okay hi everyone we are doing a working
session talking about multi-computation
and its implementation involving
language
and
so
last time
uh
one of the things that we had
evolved to is the question of
when you're
operating i mean we're okay we've got
several different things going on maybe
is this is this new or is this what we
saw before nick this is what we saw
before
have you been completely quantum since
we since we lost
stuff well i did a little bit work on
patterns
ah okay
it's not complete yet
there's some difficulties here
do you want to talk about that i mean
you're talking about pattern regulation
functions
yeah like find
pattern instance apart and instance
but it's very unclear i i i need some
more time to figure out stuff
you know i was just looking at some
to-do lists from five years ago
and one of the things that was on there
was this thing that just says match list
or matches list
which is the thing we talked about last
time of just showing the bindings
for patent variables and so on
i don't know whether you i mean that's a
very straightforward thing that i think
we should have
um
okay but but
so
let's again
refocus on what we think we know
about
what's happening here i mean we've got
uh
you know on the one hand we've got
evaluation graphs
and that's um
uh ian
do i do i have some notes here let me
see
i have notes um
oh yeah i have tons of notes here wait a
minute we've got a 22 wait we've got
this to-do list right i don't want to
repeat this again
okay
so we've got first these things for
pattern manipulation
and
basically nick you say you are working
on these is that right
well yeah some of them are quite
unclear what's exactly what they should
do okay well that's true
especially when there's some weird
pattern
primitives like accept
so you have to if you want to come up
with the instance of accept it's like
some kind of finding a negative pattern
and how that would
play out i don't know
okay well so wait a minute find pattern
instance
you so let's say
accept zero
what do you generate for that pattern
instance
well i will generally just well first of
all i want to distinguish between like
an expression and a pattern like a
pattern
is any expression that has at least one
primitive pattern primitive like one of
those vibrating alternatives except or
whole pattern whatever
blanks so
and
pattern its instance not necessarily
produces an expression without patterns
more than primitives
it just
kind of lowers their quantity
you can go one level down button higher
in some way why is there a hierarchy
well because for example you can have an
expression that for example in
alternatives you can have another
pattern primitive way cannot accept
alternatives or alternatives is flat but
maybe some other part of the primitive
so basically you can enumerate buttons
the patterns themselves
why do we think find pattern instance is
useful
other than for sort of pedagogical
purposes
yeah that i don't know
the most useful
the most useful function is unifying
expressions and patterns
so if they don't have any named patterns
so what is the unification i'm gonna do
so i could there's some main pattern and
there's a
way to
substitute
it with some expression so the two
patterns become equal then that's useful
but if there's no name patterns
is there and there still can be some
unification
okay
and maybe you could produce some sort of
way of addressing the different
you know the different sort of all the
blanks all the pattern primitives that
got replaced and like you use their
position
if you know what i
i think this is mean general feature
because we gotta you know one of the
things we got to know here is the what
happened in a replacement that's the
thing that we're going to need for many
purposes right
um
let me just save this in the right place
okay so this is about patterns
okay so i mean again
what we what we already think we need
i don't quite know why it's not listed
here
is the
i mean is all the stuff to do with um
you know match matches list and so on
or something whatever that's called
right the thing that that tells us
um
you know
i don't know exactly which way round it
is but let's say x blank x blank comma
f of six six
and that would go to
you know
i think we talked about this last time
did we not
remind me i i pointed out that multi
replace without right hand side of rules
basically produces a much list
okay
well
so
but i think we need this function and
the point that you made previously is it
can have multiple results correct
yeah
there are multiple ways of doing it by
the way in the agenda i also included
this
concept called moodiness it's like all
possible ways
like in the end
all possible ways that there can be
multiple results when you're doing a
substitution
okay like fundamental ways to having
those
okay
and so
i mean that's related okay let's again
zoom out i mean the things we're trying
to achieve as we've been talking about
for many times here
are these things here this is
these are kind of end points that we
want
now
uh
yes and we've also talked about okay so
let's again go through
did we make any progress on find
replacement find equational path for
those
progress no progress
i mean i don't want to speak on behalf
of nick stephen i don't think much
progress has been made on this at all
it's going to be made after the summer
school
yeah okay so mike that's that's what we
discuss
sure that's the proof
objective is kind of
in the process
and those things are related to those at
least find the
question okay so what's happening with
proof object
oh there's some
disagreements
then this is a good meeting to discuss
it
can somebody explain what the
disagreement is
well i guess i can so
i can also if you want
okay go ahead
yes
so i think there are two types of
disagreement we discussed in the last
meeting the structure part and we agreed
on how to
how to do that and then there is the
other part which is that the proofs have
changed a lot because the proofs are now
by contradiction
the result
is in my opinion rather strange which
it may be fine it's actually faster
which may be good but the proofs are
kind of much simpler to the point that i
find them difficult to understand
okay can we see some examples nick do
you want to share and can we look at
some examples
okay give me give me a minute
okay
so i mean
clearly whatever find occasional proof
does and has done for the last however
many years
it has to keep on being able to do
so whatever we're adding must be a
different path right
right i think we could for example add
an option and then the user specifies
whether
uh a direct ah an explicit proof is
wanted or perhaps a contradiction proof
is wanted
why is the contradiction proof easier to
do
that i don't know
because it's much shorter
in general because you don't have to
well it's not the
fact that you're doing contradiction
it's the fact that your
your variables is like you're trying to
find variables instead of like explicit
constants
because basically it's how worldmaester
works it's not even
the proof itself i don't know because
like i can
expect let's look at an example when
you're ready let's look at an example
okay
so um there's a question for ian while
you're getting ready nick
um
the evaluation graph stuff
how how has that developed
so there's an internal documentation
page for trace graph
[Music]
and i need to submit that to the
function repository
okay
and so
okay
so this is so what you've actually done
is trace graph
and
and that takes
the same arguments as trace is that
right
all the options and arguments of trace
um
okay
well i'd love to see that actually what
can can you submit that to the function
repository sometime really soon
yep okay
um
it the documentation should be in cvs
if you want to look at it now yeah how
do i get to it
do i go to dr tools or some other way
so it's it's it's there as a system
function
i mean a system function documentation
or what
uh right it's in the trees context
but we imagine initially this is going
to be put in as a wfr is that correct
yep
okay
and maybe become system
[Music]
um
okay and do we think we resolved the
major can i run this by the way
yep
how do i do that
10 13 1 in the trees context
oh
snazzy
okay
hold on
so i just say trees back take this
yep
that is uninspiring what does it do
there
well there's two are you sure you don't
need to do um sometimes with paclets if
you use a symbol that isn't one of the
explicitly exported symbols it won't
load the whole packet correctly
so i know i made a lot of changes to the
tree visualization code that this used
may have introduced a bug
okay
well can you track that down but i mean
so
so here
let me try something here
i'm very interested indeed to see
something here
um hold on one second i need to find
something
do you know where i put oh hold on i can
find this
um
oh now this is brightening
yeah unfortunately this is broken
[Music]
is it totally broken
can you make sure it gets fixed i mean
does it does have the right structural
form or not
yes it's just the vertex shape function
um
sorry could uh is there somebody
let me just see
for some bizarre reason the files to do
with our upcoming summer school project
list have disappeared from the place
where i put them
earlier today
so that's a a problem that um
uh maybe kristen can go to yeah i'll
ping danielle about that yeah
it's kind of like not good at all
um
okay what i'm looking for
are those crazy nested recursive
functions did i try that test
before i'm i'm not certain if i did
um
let me see i can find one i'm sure
hold on one second
um
oh my gosh where did i put this
i'm pretty sure i had an example
there's a great one of these necessary
recursive functions
oh drat
uh
oh gosh okay hold on
um
here we go
this is the function although it's full
of gunk here
okay
this is it and get rid of the sows
yeah just get n minus one
and why that one is there
n minus f of n minus one
is this really right
i don't know if this is right
well
let's try that okay
okay
okay let's try this if that works
oh come on
is this just completely broken
and the
the structure of the graph is correct
well i don't think it is style it's
wrong i i don't think it is correct you
trace original goes to true
and here
so if i how would i get rid of all that
gun to just see the structure of the
graph
i'm sorry
and leg voltage iii
is it a tree
um
well if i just say graph oh no no this
is a graph sorry make a shape function
goes to automatic maybe
why is the automatic top of the
autocomplete list there
okay
oh this is cool
this is really cool
okay hold on let's just do um
let's just do a slightly smaller one of
these
okay have i done this before i i have a
tremendous sense of deja vu here
i mean this is some kind of
um something must be wrong here
no i don't understand this i'm doing
does this have a memorizer
oh stupid stupid it has a memorizer
forget that
okay
without memorization
oh my gosh that's already that
complicated
oh it may go to negative values this is
really cool
so i mean this is a recursive evaluation
it's a non-trivial recursive evaluation
showing
and now what i should be able to see
here
is different forms of recursion both
re-evaluation recursion and
um
sort of recursion through the expression
how do i see that in oh so let's just
try f of one here the dashed red lines
are where a transformation rule gets
applied
okay and the solid edges are
for
subsidiary evaluations
okay
so f of zero better be trivial that just
let it go
i don't even understand why that goes
through so much connection
to get to its result
now if i just say trace the f calls is
that going to work or is that going to
be
yep
you can do the symbol f or a pattern
oh
that's weird
is that obvious
that it always has to be kind of like a
a single well let's try something like
for three that's really weird
is that obvious that that has to work
that way
that's can you see that
yeah but look at what this is doing this
is going
yeah here we can see the actual choice
i don't
understand
because this should show sub
sub expression
evaluation right which shouldn't be
looking like this
there's reevaluation
evaluation so to speak and then the
sub-expression evaluation
i don't understand how this could
possibly be right
can you do them with the expression
evaluations because of all of the layers
of nested lists but they don't contain
anything other than
f's because the pattern
i understand that but what we are trying
to show
in the trace graph is the difference
between
in here there is it's going to do the
sub-expression evaluation here
that's separate
i'm i'm really confused why why is it
just linear do you think it's right that
it's just linear
in this case yeah
look look at the neck the next thing
after that expression in the trace is
that big nested list
and then there's nothing after that
sorry what are you saying
in the traces well okay so if i say this
one minus f minus one
quite my point of view
um
so wait a minute those are those are
with the pluses
but with f alone
what are you saying there's
i don't understand why this f of three
doesn't have a sub piece evaluating f of
three minus one
well
the f of three doesn't but the f of
three minus one does and that's why the
next element after that is
wrapped in another level of list
okay but why doesn't that show up here
in any way
it's the it's like i said it's the solid
edges or sub-expression recursion
and the
dashed red edges are the
transformation rules
but there's no
multi because these functions are all of
one argument is that why
is that why this is looking like this
if these functions had two arguments it
wouldn't look like this
yeah
i think
and and sort of having one argument is
kind of like being trivial with respect
to space somehow
i think maybe
okay well when when we've got the
certain labels properly we can really
look at this this is really good
okay um nick are you ready to do your
demo
are you on sharing oh yeah sorry go
ahead
so
basically the main change here was
for this simple
firmware for simple axiom
it's like previously it was actually
treating it
as instead of universal quantifier it
was an existential quantifier so this is
exactly produces an old style proof
it's just the only difference that there
is exists one here instead of for all
but but is it proving a different thing
it's probably the same thing but
differently it's like this proof
when there is a four-row quantifier on
the top level for your hypothesis it
the default point is actually to prove
it by contradiction
so what it's doing is actually hold on
hold on i want to clarify something
in terms of what find equational proof
like my favorite example for my boolean
algebra axiom okay i want to prove p dot
q equals q dot p
right
from that from that axiom it's the other
way around it's first p dot q equals q
dot p
and it's a center dot
okay
okay so now this is now so what this is
the thing
okay
is that the traditional proof or is that
a new proof
that's a traditional proof because i
haven't used the quantifier here okay so
now put in a quantifier yeah
okay so that's the thing i thought i was
proving
now it's much much simpler what
how could that possibly be
okay show me the proof
it's basically just one critical value
i'm going to require it here
and choose a proof notebook
okay maybe
i am totally confused okay so that's
like the word thing
so you see the wording we would like to
show that true equal fonts
if we are going to prove a contradiction
we start we need to start by rewarding
that
because we don't want to show there is
quite false yeah i know but there's a
much more serious problem okay so you
know right now you know i've had for the
last 20 something years this proof of
you know that boolean algebra axiom
are you telling me that there is a
vastly simpler proof that could be given
well i don't i don't really believe in
yeah yeah well you're
kind of doubting it right now too but i
think it should be correct because if i
mean that's a very non-trivial thing to
prove
even constructive it's not constructive
so what do you mean but what the heck is
it proving
look i don't even see the axioms here
where are the axioms here
direction one
i guess it's not even required to prove
it
this is nonsense sorry
this is nonsense
q dot p is not generically equal to p
dot q
so
it can be used somewhere
because there's some non-trivial
i think this just isn't right
i mean
look look
to prove p dot q equals q dot p
it takes all kinds of gymnastics given
that axiom
okay let's do the following let's take
the original let's say axiomatic theory
of water maximums just let's get the
axiom okay
just just get it get it explicitly out
just
okay now let's use that axiom but let's
edit it okay just use it raw just just
enter that thing and we're going to just
you know edit it in some random way
okay now now put put up you know put a
just change one of the b's to an a or c
or something i don't care what you do c
dots or something
okay all right now let's try again
it's not using it for some reason i
agree just
okay but the setup
but the setup is
whatever the setup is it's trying it's
just
it's just wrong something that's just
gone wrong here
okay i i think we should consider this a
bug
but i don't think that proof by
contradiction well i mean here proof by
contradiction is doing the wrong thing
but
do we have a case where we can see that
it's doing the right thing
you mean where it's actually used using
the axiom yes i guess there's a bunch of
those
like well this is the classical one form
okay let's see that run i mean so
well this is the
i see that's got a predicate
but
well that it's not going to be changed
much from the previous results because
it's still
an existential quantifier in the
hypothesis so it's the same
but if you think
i have another commander
i have another comment i would like to
make can you open that
summary box
socrates
yes
so this one has
these two new fields variables and
constants
has been added
and how this works is that because this
is an equational proofer
there is a conversion of these things
into a an equational language and that
introduces internal variables now i
wonder whether we should actually report
that we introduce 15 internal variables
and whether that's useful or not
well if they show up in the proof
i think it is useful yes
or definitely useful for actually
extracting some for example a proof
proof function from the
proof itself but jose what's your point
i mean the fact that we have to
introduce these internal variables i
mean we have to do that even in the in
cases other than you know predicates
like this don't we i mean i think
well my point is that in a sense the
conversions to equational language some
sort of internal method to prove this
if we had that first or a general first
order logic prover we would we wouldn't
have to do this conversion
right so
i mean i can imagine that we could do
different conversions
and then they would introduce different
numbers of variables well i mean look we
can make different proofs too
i mean it's just to find equational
proof i mean it doesn't guarantee to be
the smallest whatever
right and in general we can imagine a
method where it would end up without
generating intermediate you know
you know new variables
right
in a sense this is like reporting on how
many internal module variables we have
created and so it looks too internal to
me
well is it would it show up in the
actual proof
sure
very
much yeah c1 and all that
see the fact that they actually show up
in the proof if they do where are they
the 15 of them supposed to be
what's the actual variables
i don't understand something has gone
wrong here maybe they're not
necessarily part of the proof
well but then i don't care about them
i mean what what matters the fact that
somewhere in the bowels of the of the
implementation it generated random
variables who cares i mean it might have
generated those on a path that it
decided not to take
and that's a distinctly don't care type
situation
it looks like it generated one new
variable here
am i right
i mean that's what we should be counting
and that's interesting to know it seems
to me
well i think this
particular case is actually so many
variables because
i'm
counting them separately for each action
maybe that's the problem oh i see so
they've been renamed
so there's a limited number of canonical
names
because in a sense what we're
effectively doing is scoping each one of
those axioms is really scoped
to that axiom
is that right
i mean that's gonna bite us eventually
but that does not explicitly show
scoping
well when they you just show the axiom
on its own it's fine you can
canonicalize all this but when you feed
it into some equation if you improve
you may want to distinguish that this
variable actually came from this axiom
well but look in general every axiom
will get used many times and its
variables are scoped to within that
axiom and those variable those explicit
names will be reu you know changed each
times it's each time it's used just like
module variables
right
those variable names don't mean anything
in any of these in any of these axioms
they're always going to get renamed
and the fact that they're called abc
here is just for pure
physio convenience that we can
canonicalize them separately
am i right yeah
right
okay look bottom line here there seems
to be some kind of bug so i don't think
i mean is there anything else we can
look at without
without resolving that in in this stuff
here
you mean viable case for the no no no no
no no no the basic case is broken so
it's hard to know what we're supposed to
look at right the basic equational case
is broken yeah
right so jose was saying he doesn't like
the fact that it's proven by
contradiction but the fact is isn't
proving anything because it's broken
okay right so we can't really look at it
without without resolving that
how do you give you that it's just i'm
pretty sure that the proof what whatever
proof is set up it's like we're trying
to prove
this new hypothesis
like true equals false and with the new
additional action that's what we are
doing if it somehow managed to do that
but it didn't it didn't this is done
nothing right it can prove it it proved
it even in the case where we just
changed the axioms to make it nonsense
it just sort of blindly says i can prove
anything
i'm just a nature of this particular
hypothesis i don't know
but it's clearly wrong i'm sorry it's
it's you know look we've got an axiom
here that asserts something
i
okay look why don't we just say
i know what we want to do here we just
just
you know just give an axiom system for
which this clearly isn't true i don't
know p dot p equals p
try and prove that p dot p equals p
p dot p equals p
yeah
hold on
i think it is
it's nonsense i'm sorry
you maybe this one is broken because it
looked like by the way there were some
there was some confirmation failed in
the proof
yeah
so this one i can't trust because the
proof function was also wrong
okay look i think it's just a bug
somewhere i don't think we should we
should spend a lot of effort
um
but i want to come back to what the
issue of principle which i don't think
we can resolve here which was you are
trying to rearrange these proofs to be
proofs by contradiction
i don't really understand why i'm not
doing it explicitly it's what what
meister doing
it's like in this in it's called it's
when your
hypothesis is
uh
not grounded basically when it has
variables it's doing it explicitly there
it's adding this additional axiom and
trying to prove okay
something has gone wrong so i think we
need to resolve what's gone wrong before
we can continue this discussion but is
there any further
you know
i mean and whatever it's doing
you know it was obviously made to do
something which seems to have been
almost correct previously
but for some bugs
whereas now it seems to have gone
completely off the deep end
so i'm i mean what can we do usefully
here on this i think jose is there
anything else you want to bring up here
because i just don't think we can
discuss this until it actually works
i agree with that i suggest that we add
an option so that
users can choose which type of proof
they want so that i like the future yeah
not everything just relies only on
contradictions
yeah i think that's fine
i mean i think so by the way i mean to
ask a more naive question i mean if the
reason is we're doing this proof by
contradiction because that's how
waldmeister does
does you know
for all statements basically i mean is
there a reason why we don't try and make
some connection to some other first
order logic
prover
i i i don't think this is how you know i
think this isn't something's gone wrong
here okay because this is not you know
for the last however many years we've
had a thing which doesn't do proof by
contradiction so we clearly have a way
to do that
so i something is confused here
but you know it took significant effort
20 years ago
to
you know
and and
it leverages good software engineering
that was done uh you know by the group
that developed world meister and so on i
think it is non-trivial to connect to
other things
and these things are require more
babysitting than you expect
uh i mean it's something we could
investigate but i don't see the point at
the this moment
i think it's more interesting if we have
fundamentally different kinds of proofs
okay there's some there's some stuff
that has to be resolved here but the
thing that we had really wanted to talk
about is how do we take proof objects
and make them be more useful so i mean
nick you you have a proof function there
which still looks kind of impenetrable
right i mean this is this is what we
want to clean up because this proof
function
is also like an evaluation graph is it
not
i mean there's a very close
correspondence between
a proof graph
and an evaluation i mean the the yeah
the proof graph and the evaluation graph
is there not
in other words what this is doing is
it's saying
you know
oh yeah
it's like each result of each lemma
is constructed here explicitly
right
right so so that's what i'm saying is is
what
i mean so that's what we're trying to
represent
in the evaluation graph we're trying to
do the exact same kind of thing so what
i'm what i'm hoping for is that we can
have a unified approach
to showing kind of the innards of a
computation
if that makes sense
so that we can so that they're
composable and so we can do computations
on you know what we want to do is comp
meta computations on the computation
am i making sense
right so so we have either a path
that we you know we either have the
evaluation
graph
look the vision is is obviously this
we've got
in the past we've only been interested
in input output
now we're going to actually display the
evaluation graph
we're also going to display
uh
but but the evaluation graph is merely a
single way evaluation graph
it is one path through a multi-way
evaluation graph except that we have
chosen a particular evaluation order so
that we make it single way
in the case of a proof object
there is no the the choice of which i
mean this is a single way
uh you know computation
but which single way computation it is
is not chosen in the same way that we
would choose it
in standard evaluation where it's just
you know whatever it is um
you know left most innermost or whatever
in the most left most but whatever it is
um what is it actually is it is it left
most innermost i think it is
um
does that make sense it's some other
i mean you know just as and this relates
also to the naming of of traversal
orders right because we're talking about
uh
left most innermost
you know to make a proof
if we were to
represent every possible choice by some
integer or something the proof might be
you know one seven three four eight two
four or something showing at each
at each branch where where do you go in
the multi-way graph
whereas in some sense the standard
evaluation order is like 1 1 1 1
in the multi-way graph
is that making sense to people
so i mean what we want is a uniform what
we want to be able to do
both for
proofs
we should be able to make the full
entailment cone which is the full
multi-way graph for evaluations that's
what multi-evaluate does
you know it makes the full evaluation
full multi-way evaluation graph
which then
by
uh you know we can look only at that
particular path
that corresponds to ordinary evaluation
the theorem prover
is
finding it it's like find replace path
which i keep on wanting us to really
really get implemented
it is finding a particular path
and you know again we can make
an evaluation you know we make a
representation of that evaluation
process
aka a piece of the evaluation graph
right i guess that this is again a
complete evaluation graph of the of the
non-multi-way kind
this making
sense let's go back to my screen
um by the way i put some code in chat to
fix the trace graph output
oh good okay
oh lovely
okay
well that was a bit more complicated
than we expected okay so let's say f of
two for example here
oh my gosh
okay so now if i say f of 2 with f
vertical bar plus here
what am i seeing here
okay can i get it to just do f blank not
do the f's themselves
yeah
can i just do that
yep
and what do i do here do i say verbatim
or what do i say
oh actually if i just say underscore
plus that should work
okay now i'm super confused
i just don't understand this
how did it go from f of two okay it's
got this now why is it not branching
there
it's sub evaluating two minus f of two
minus one got rid of the other branches
with the pattern
why
because it's still got an f there i
don't understand it should have a place
where the evaluator has to dig in
the only argument of that expression is
the one expression that you see there if
it was two arguments then there would be
another branch
so are you telling me i mean if i did
the same thing for fibonacci
uh
i see that there's a plus there that is
but i understand the plus will have two
arguments in plenty of places
i am totally confused
okay i am oh i mean this is at least i'm
less confused now because this is what i
would have expected it to do more or
less
let's just look at the the ordinary
fibonacci piece
oh
okay let's see if i understand this
why does it even show that one
okay fiber five evaluates defibrillator
5 minus 1 plus 4 5 minus 2.
what's that line there that's showing an
evaluation of sub-evaluation
that's that's showing a transformation
rule being applied why isn't there
something shown here as a transformation
rule figure five going from five minus
one to plus five y minus two why isn't
that a transformation rule get rid of
the second argument
so there you see the transformation rule
from five of three to
the three minus one plus fib of three
minus two
okay
you did you didn't wanna you didn't
include plus in the pattern last time so
that node was skipped so you just had
the direct edges to fib of three minus
one and fit with three minus two okay so
if i go here
underscore fib or under store plus
and i say favor five
okay that's an evaluation
that's sub-expressions
sub-expression
oh gosh this is this crazy pullback
business
that happened there right which we don't
have a great representation for
you understand what i'm saying
it it it nested it it really hurts down
to this and then it pulls back to that
which is clearer without the pattern but
i agree it's very hard to tell
what's happening do you have a comment
about this i mean how does this relate
to
the other kind of or james for that
matter i mean the things that we've been
doing
this is like super obscure
in combinators we have this weird um
oh gosh what were we calling them uh
pseudo
oh my gosh what the heck was i calling i
guess another problem is
not clear if that's a
deconstruction or or a reconstruction it
happens to be a reconstruction
well right this is a going back up
okay this line
this is not going to cut it right that
that line there is the same as that line
there
because this is a drill down and this is
a
build back
up so oh gosh how do we represent this
we talked about
maybe flaring
the edge
yeah
but what really is going on here i mean
in other words in the process of
evaluation
what was i calling i was calling them
pullback pseudo-events i think
which is just the most disgusting i mean
even that very name tells you it's a
crazy concept
again nick can you comment on i mean in
terms of
an event graph
this is clearly an event
that red thing is clearly you could put
an event here
yeah
but all of our evaluation graphs are
one-to-one events they just take one
expression and turn it into
i'm really confused here
anybody help i mean okay do people at
least understand why i'm confused
that this is drill down this is pull
back up
yeah and that and that is confusing when
when you have a second argument pattern
because it removes a bunch of nodes from
the graph that would otherwise clarify
what's happening well let's see how it
clarifies i mean if it clarified what
what else do i have to include to help
clarify
just remove the second argument i i know
that but it's going to then get very
very very complicated
right so we're not going to know until
you remove it
i mean it seems like the the unintuitive
thing is the fact that the f is
disappearing and then like coming back
if you know what i mean like there's no
uh
it's like it's pulling information out
from
from the east coast
right and so i guess the symbol fib
would be another thing to add to the
alternatives not just
blank fib okay but hold on what happened
here
so where was the pullback happening here
this fib of four minus one so so you see
it's got these two branches
one is trivial it just has the fib
and then the other branch is the four
minus one becoming three
right
and then those two things feed into the
fib of three
right so the problem was that that left
branch that is just fib wasn't included
because it doesn't have head fib and it
said symbol
right okay so let's just try for here
four and then going straight into
the three
okay so let's say or fib
do like
blank integer
why do i want blank integer as well
so here you see you have a four minus
one
but you never see three by itself
anywhere
right but the problem before was
in here all i see is four minus one i
see i'm not seeing the carrying
this has deconstructed itself down to
fib
of four minus one and that
deconstruction is visible here
see what i'm saying
yeah
but that deconstruction has not visible
in the other case
right
but where's three all you can infer from
the other case
assuming you can tell that it's a
deconstruction edge
is that four minus one gets evaluated
as a
subsidiary evaluation
but you don't see what it evaluates to
you just see
the end result is fib of three
okay but i want to remind us
okay
you know nick has proposed this
formalism where everything is a
hypograph
essentially what's happening here that
the confusion is we are used to seeing
expressions as single unified things
but what's happening here is as we look
more granularly
at how the evaluation happens every
expression is shattered into its
sub-pieces
and the difficulty is i mean it's the
same difficulty okay so we've got we've
got the two different difficulties
actually nick i don't understand in your
proofs you have the same
reconstructionists you do you not
you can end up doing a subtree
transformation which then has to be
pulled back into the full tree
is that true
well
when i do an approve function yes
yes
you can make a transformation of a
subtree
and the way you're representing that is
you're saying
i mean you're then going to use that
subtree that has been transformed and
it's going to get pulled back into a
bigger expression is it not
no it's kind of straightforward to just
to replace that
that's what it means to pull back a sub
3.
fine but then then okay but then can we
think of this doing replace that
this is doing replace that as well i
mean it's doing replace that of of the
first part in favor four minus one of
four minus one with three
so in a sense
these edges which here are just shown as
a single edge
in the proof object case would be
annotated by
the part number of the replace that that
is operating there am i correct
yeah when you have numbers it becomes
very
easy to see what's going on
right but the point that i'm making is
the evaluator
is a giant festival of replacements
basically
it's just doing a bunch of replaceats
in a particular order
but right now we are not recording where
those replaceats happen
instead here we are recording the
lineage
of that replace that was the result of a
sub-evaluation of this thing here
whereas
in the theorem prover you are explicitly
recording the part numbers at which the
replace ads occur
am i right
yep okay
but
one of the issues with that is the part
numbers are not very stable
and as soon as the transformation has
been done it's new part numbers
i don't know that's an issue or not but
i mean it tells you for every step it
tells you
you're making these i mean we could do
we could do the exact same thing here we
could if we had
if
the
you know think of the evaluator
as a super axiom called a vowel let's
say
then at each place here we could be
saying that that edge there is replace
that
of
or maybe map out if it's just using a
vowel but doesn't really matter replace
that effectively
on fiber four minus one part one
with what you get from replacing with
the vowel am i right
yes and i just want to add the caveat
for the standard evaluation sequence if
you have non-standard evaluation
then it's not a replace at you get
arbitrary deconstruction and arbitrary
reconstruction
not just replacing a sub-expression with
a new one
what do you mean you mean the vowel
actually does something non-trivial it
runs internal code on the whole object
yeah you you
so you deconstruct the expression here
you're deconstructing it into just the
things at level one
but you could deconstruct it into just
totally arbitrary expressions that have
nothing to do with the original
expression structure
what would make you do that
let's say you had a function with a hold
attribute okay okay that's the case but
the main point is with it with a hold
attribute
the internal code is gulping the whole
innards of the function
without having done sub-evaluation
right and and the point is there will
still be subsidiary evaluations
and they'll still be denoted exactly the
same way
they'll happen somehow mediated by the
internal code in some way
this is much more obscure
yeah
okay that's a different case so there's
two categories there's either the
evaluation of an expression at level one
or
totally anything with non-standard
evaluation
next you're going to say something
it's going to show you you can still can
record all the parts numbers for the
inputs and how you do the construction
basically when you do the reconstruction
you
you when you do evaluation first you
extract some part numbers do some
computation then you construct it into a
new expression with new part numbers
so
there's still information there
even for arbitrary
right i just want to
go back to our big road map for a second
yet again
um although you've yeah okay so
the big road map talks about
you know the pattern stuff we've talked
about that a little bit i understand i i
think we should be thinking carefully
about what we actually want here and
what's going to be used for
the evaluation graph
well we've we've got this composability
issue here and we've got these issues
about
uh
understanding pullbacks
so there's some there's some questions
there
yeah i mean we really do have a road map
and we really do need to actually get
implementing a bunch of these things
i mean
this one is again we've talked about
this a million times this is the
multi-way case where we're finding a
single path
and where
you know find replace path and this is a
point for
find replace pass could in principle
take
um a traversal order
option
find replace path becomes stupid if it
takes the traversal order option
in the sense that then you're just
telling it the path
does that make sense to people
of course yeah
right and so
i mean although you might want to
partially tell it the path
you know
and you certainly want um
you know at each decision point you can
imagine it you know scratching its head
and using machine learning or something
to decide which
path it should try
is that something we think we can
parametrize or is it going to end up
with something like the horror of brett
first search
which is not unrelated to find replace
path
and leave it as an option
like what basically is a
supplier function that decides where to
move next
based on what
based on your
current history
and
so it's like a fold type thing where it
works knows what the path has been so
far and it's asked where would you like
to go next
yeah
and maybe not just a single part but
also all the alternative
paths that it took
because maybe just was wandering around
well also maybe that had already tried
taking future paths and it's now
backtracked from a future path and this
is the only you know and there's no
point in retrying a future path that
already took
yeah basically a whole previous graph
that the graph at this point
is constructed
i will hold on a second hold on a second
i mean potentially
include
its complete
exploration graph what the heck is an
exploration graph i mean in other words
in other words i understand the final
path and i understand the full multi-way
graph but what is this exploration path
is it a partial multi-way graph
yeah
i don't see a difference
so it's a sub-graph of the multi-rate
graph
yep
i think that's right
yeah i think maybe not just just for sub
graph but like you have like a sub
because you have to
start from the root
it have to include the root
okay fine i mean which is which is
basically a subgraph that includes them
yeah i mean
we're not what i'm saying we're not
saying it's any subgraph the exploration
graph is not any subgraph it but it is a
sub graph
is it not
yeah
so here's an interesting point
if you've got
an exploration path let's imagine that
you feed in
well okay so composability of find
replace path
is ultimately it's a graph union of
exploration graphs
i claim
that the full multi-way graph is a graph
union of expiration paths expiration
graphs
just like for a proof object one can
imagine
well what the heck does it look like
what is the composition of two proof
objects
in a sense that would be a proof object
is like a path
that would be you're going from this
root
set of axioms
to this theorem
and then you go on from that theorem to
another theorem
i mean is that
the question is what what is the what
what kind of composability is there for
proof graphs what kind of composability
is there for evaluation graphs
basically it exists
some kind of composability
yeah
right
right but okay the thing i keep on
pushing for is a unified treatment of
the evaluation graph and the proof graph
because i think they are the same thing
they're both they're both
you know
single-way slices of the multi-way graph
the evaluation graph might seem like a
more natural one because it is just
going down the left most you know
innermost evaluation path whereas the
general proof graph was carefully found
you know to navigate down to the result
i just want to look for a second at your
also the difference between evaluation
graph and proof graph is proof graph is
uh
how is it it's it's a cumulative right
so you can imagine what evolution would
look like if you would generate new down
values as it evaluates
just like everything is memorized
yeah
something like that
well that's interesting yeah go ahead
it's just not memorized you have to
it's like computation
you generate new computation it's it's
not just memorizing anything
it's more than that
new rules new down values as rules and
not just remember the output
but i think
you mean new down values of the form f
of x like no that's because okay
in a
in an ordinary evaluation
everything is a literal at the time it's
evaluated
or almost unless you're constructing
code on the fly
whereas in the case of a proof
you are constructing the statement x
blank dot y blank equals y blank dot x
blank
which can then be applied as a pattern
to other things
whereas that's not something you do in
ordinary evaluation
yeah exactly that's what they say you
can imagine what would it look like if
it actually did
it's a different well if it proved
intermediate theorems in the case
if it said i've just got the straight
evaluation but i will be able to
evaluate faster if i prove this
intermediate theorem
like if the evaluator
said you know
nest
append or fold some kind of fold of
append
um
that that's equivalent to a join
and it could just
do that transformation internally and
you're claiming that that's what the
theorem prover effectively is doing by
generating lemmas
generating lemmas causes it to jump
ahead and not go through every step
whereas the evaluator does not have a
mechanism to do that
the evaluator has no way to prove micro
lemmas so to speak that allow it to jump
ahead
i guess
unless there's some optimization
but in general
right i mean but that's what you're
saying that's what the proof object does
manage to let one do so it's an
interesting thing as you say to think
about what would happen if you were able
to do that in ordinary evaluation
we should wrap up here but but okay i
mean clearly clearly the main thing
needs to happen is just actual progress
on this these pieces of implementation
and where there no doubt will be things
run into
that are difficult and that's what these
meetings are about is to try to resolve
those
um
okay anything else we should make sure
to go over right now
nope okay thanks everybody i'm i'm glad
to see this trace go off do do ian you
will put in that fix right so that so
that we get trace graph
really in 13 yep
okay